les médecins libéraux frôle
l'hypertension nouvelle grève de main
pour dénoncer les tarifs de consultation
mais aussi la loi riste qui permettait
aux patients en accès direct à certains
soignants à Tours 142 médecins viennent
de signer une lettre ouverte avant la
manifestation parisienne à laquelle se
joindra cette inédit l'ordre des
médecins les la Turquie
pas de rendez-vous à l'agenda ce mardi
c'est une nouvelle journée de grève qui
se profile pour les médecins libéraux
l'une des raisons la négociation
actuelle de la convention médicale avec
l'assurance maladie elle fixe notamment
les tarifs de consultation pour les cinq
prochaines années aujourd'hui la
consultation de base est à 25 euros et
la CPAM propose une hausse d'un euro 50
qu'on ne travaillerait pas assez donc si
on veut accéder à des niveaux de
rémunération supérieure il faudrait
travailler encore plus en attire plus
quoi donc voilà donc ça nous permettrait
si ça bougeait de ce côté-là de
permettre et ben au plus jeune ou 40%
qui s'installent jamais de s'installer
et peut-être à ceux qui sont plus âgés
de pas partir de façon anticipée un
mouvement d'ampleur et une annonce
inédite la participation de l'ordre des
médecins à l'Inter syndical une première
depuis la création de l'Ordre en cause
la loi riste en discussion au Sénat elle
permettrait de ne plus obligatoirement
passer par un médecin pour obtenir
certaines prescriptions elle pourrait
être fournie par exemple par des
infirmières de pratica avancées ou des
kinésithérapeutes cette loi elle va être
à l'origine d'une organisation du
système de santé et on remet pas du tout
en cause les compétences de nos
confrères infirmières kinésithérapeutes
d'orthophoniste mais un accès direct
sans aucune régulation médicale c'est
pas possible une stratégie thérapeutique
elle ne peut être mise en place que par
des médecins qui ont été formés pour ça
en Indre-et-Loire 142 médecins viennent
de signer une lettre ouverte expliquant
leur crainte pour l'avenir de la
profession parmi eux médecins installé
remplaçant spécialiste et hospitaliers
tous réunis dont certains qui vont
rejoindre la capitale ce mardi pour
grossir les routes de la manifestation